it's been a pretty hectic week for me
guys and in less than 12 hours I have to
jump on a plane to be out of here
so hence why I haven't had time to
change into my usual clothes and I'm
still in very professional work attire
but hey there's nothing wrong with that
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
Tommy and welcome back to the channel if
you're new here thank you so much for
joining me a little bit about myself my
name's David Tomich I'm a masters of
architecture graduate and I'm an
entrepreneur I've successfully launched
three businesses that have gone
international
one being wire watches which is now
stocked across 14 stores in three
different continents on this channel we
talk a lot about tech and tech reviews
and today we're talking about something
that's been out for about six months in
beta but it's only been officially
released to the public a couple weeks
ago we're talking about apples
brand new Catalina update which allows
you to enable sidecar and use any Apple
pencil enabled iPad and any 2016 or
later macbook into a dual screen setup
yes I know you've been able to pair your
iPads to Mac books for a long time now
using lots of different third-party
devices third buddy programs and even
different cables that you've had to go
out and buy but this is the first time
that Apple has released the software
officially and it's a hundred cents rate
if you've just clicked on this video and
have absolutely no idea what sidecar is
basically what it does is it lets you
mirror your screen from your laptop to
any Apple supported device at the moment
it's any Apple pencil supported iPad so
any iPad iPad Mini or iPad pro the
latest generations and a couple
generations back and also any Apple TV
compatible devices now there are a few
things that you need to take note if you
want to activate this first of all you
need to have the Catalina update
installed on your laptop you need to
have iPad OS installed on your iPad and
you need to have both devices running on
the same iCloud now for me I had a
little bit of trouble setting this up I
didn't have any of my Apple
set up with two-factor authorization
they were just enabled with a single
sign-in so I had to go through and set
up the iPad set up the laptop set up an
iPhone get it all synched get it all
running and it was a bit of a pain in
the butt if I'm being honest but when
you actually got it all working it was
really good and really worthwhile so
sidecar is very simple to set up if
you've never used it before all we have
to do is go to the top right hand corner
of your screen click the little airplay
button and drop down to where you see
your iPads name click it and the rest is
done for you if for some reason you're
still having some trouble finding your
iPad some pro tips are make sure you're
connected to the same iCloud account
make sure both your Bluetooth and your
Wi-Fi is turned on on both devices and
finally make sure you are on the same
Wi-Fi network this will not work if
you're not on the same Wi-Fi network so
this is definitely your first
troubleshooting point now what you'll
find once you've activated sidecar on
your iPad is the simple fact that your
iPad is no longer a hundred percent
touchscreen there is a small little
sliver on the side that has a few menu
options for you that is still
touchscreen and allows you to disable
the sidecar at any point in time it's
good to know that you can also use your
iPad as normal click the home button
it'll take you back to the home screen
and you can still use your all your apps
as regular and activate the touch
functionality again a little golden
nugget from Apple though since they have
completely removed all touch
functionalities from the iPad they've
made sure to include the little touch
bar at the bottom of the iPad when
you've got sidecar running so even if
your MacBook doesn't have the touch bar
on it you'll get this feature on your
iPad now mine doesn't have the touch bar
so it is proof that it works however
when I was testing this out and having a
good play with it I really found that
every time I try to use the touch but it
never really worked it was kind of like
that whole section of the iPad was
frozen when I moved the touch bar up to
the top of the screen it worked for a
few minutes and then decided to stop
working again so for me the touch bar
wasn't that
useful but it might have been the iPad
it might have been a software thing I'm
not too sure maybe let me know in the
comments below if you're having the same
issue if you have the added luxury of
having an Apple pencil at your disposal
it's good to know that the Apple pencil
still works a hundred percent during the
sidecar application basically it just
works like the mouse pointer you can
click anywhere with the pencil you can
draw like you would with the pencil and
you can use your iPad as a draw tablet
so you're creative and need the power of
your laptop to do most of your work but
your laptop isn't touchscreen and you
love to draw well you can always boot up
the sidecar onto your iPad take your
iPad into your lap start drawing on
Photoshop Adobe Illustrator use the
pencil as you would very naturally with
a draw pad and have it right there at
your disposal with the full power of
your laptop in the tiny little iPad now
that's a pretty amazing feature if you
ask me and something that I'll
definitely be utilizing in the future
one thing that I got to researching
straight away and this is in no way
shape or form sponsored I just thought
it was a cool little accessory that you
can buy for this is a little mount
bracket so I think it's about 35
Australian dollars or 20 US 25 US
depending on the currency exchange rate
at the moment you can get a small little
padded bracket that sits on the side of
your laptop and clips in your iPad
directly onto the side so you don't have
to hold it you don't have to worry about
it it can literally just be your second
screen folding on the side of your
laptop that's pretty cool
definitely worthwhile if you're going to
utilize this feature a lot and have some
reading material on the side while doing
your main project on your laptop and
that's pretty much all you need to know
about the Apple side card application
it's very easy to use it's very easy to
set up and that's one of the best things
about the Apple ecosystem that's all for
me guys thank you so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video make sure you
smash the subscribe button
20:19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday